pendant 45 minutes de 7 le groupe de
reggae mal mal a fait vibrer les
planches du festival crazy tonnes
organisée pour la deuxième fois dans le
parc de folleville de thiverval grignon
l'occasion pour les sept membres du
groupe i guînois de faire passer leur
message près de chez eux
un message d'unité donc fait les grandes
phrases mais ça reste toujours des
bonnes valeurs
donc l'unité pour toutes les communautés
on est content de jouer à quatre avec
plein de groupes plein de styles
différents
et justement on est là aussi pour
représenter le reggae musique à travers
tous ces groupes de rock donc on lâche
pas la faire on est là on est très
content
et côté rock justement les cinq membres
du groupe cartes sont venus jouer leur
musique
influencé par la pop britannique d où
des beatles et des kicks c'est une
manière de jouer en fait passer une très
bonne ambiance
la scène est magnifique il fait beau on
est très bien accueilli pour cette
deuxième édition ce festival de musiques
actuelles gratuit tend à favoriser les
groupes locaux mais a surtout un
objectif majeur mettre en avant la
musique
la musique c'est un langage
international auquel on a vraiment très
attaché et donc c'est avant tout la
musique et à l'art musical 40 bénévoles
et 40 musiciens devraient cette année
pour célébrer la musique au coeur des
yvelines une nouvelle édition de ce
festival est déjà prévue pour 2017